If your entire world was suddenly destroyed
by horrifying,
godlike creatures, what would you do?
Everyone you love is dying
and no one can save you.
I'm going to break down the mistakes made,
what you should do
and how to beat the Titans
in attack on Titan.
This kid is about to lose everything,
and this town has no idea
that everyone is about to be eaten
by horrifying flesh eating monsters.
Eren, here is a small town kid
growing up inside the walled city district
of Shiganshina, with these massive walls
designed to protect humanity
from the terrifying threats that lurk right
outside.
Known as the Titans, Eren
and his childhood friend
Mikasa finished up
collecting wood and head back home.
But then they encounter a group of city
guards, a branch of the city's
military
tasked with the defense of the city walls.
However, they're all drunk on the job,
and this angers Eren,
who demands that they stand guard
and do what they're paid for protect the city
from the horrifying titans who could show up
at any moment to kill everyone.
The guards, however, laugh
at the two kids, saying that there hasn't
been an attack on any city in over 100 years
so they can chill out.
But these guards don't realize that Eren's
fears are about to come true.
It's only a matter of time before humanity's
worst threat comes back for blood.
OK, first off, these guards are idiots.
These titans have been stalking the Earth
and this city for over 100 years.
Humanity is living in a bubble
that can burst at any moment.
Walling ourselves off
is only putting a Band-Aid over two
gigantic problems, and one of those is right
outside of the walls,
and the second is within starvation
by walling off humanity.
We've created a food problem.
Pushing off and delaying the massive
Titan threat is going to lead to them
becoming greater in numbers until eventually
and probably already
half the titans outnumber humans.
This choice humanity has made
is going to lead down a series of events
that will result in the death of hundreds,
if not thousands, of innocent people.
As far as we know right now,
the Titans look like humans,
which might lead us to believe
that they reproduce in the exact same way .
However, since there haven't been
any sightings of Titan babies
and the Titans don't seem to have any male
or female organs,
there might be some other way
they're reproducing that we're not aware of.
However, regardless of the traits unique
to the Titans,
the physiology is extremely similar,
meaning the same physiological principles
should apply to them regardless of size.
Either way,
our main goal is to destroy every last titan,
so that way there's no possibility
they'll ever come back.
It's easier said than done,
but at least we know that is a possibility
as far as we know now.
The Titans aren't capable of critical
thinking, meaning that they lack the ability
to properly assess a situation
like a human would.
The most important way of beating a creature
much bigger and stronger than you
is to understand
both its strengths and weaknesses.
They should come in handy in the near future,
and it's going to provide
a lot of opportunities
to outsmart the creatures when needed.
And speaking of outsmarting creatures,
I would begin to invest time and money
into research and development
for aircraft vehicles.
This is going to grant us
the ability of aerial reconnaissance.
Now, the 3D maneuver gear is a great way
to traverse the city,
but outside it's completely useless
unless you're surrounded by trees.
Not only that, the gear can only take you
so far into the air while an airplane.
Or, dare I say, a balloon,
should be able to propel you
far enough into the air
that the Titans can't attack you.
The time between Titan attacks was around
100 years, and based on the clothing and
overall appearance of the city, it resembles
something close to early 1900s Germany.
So in theory,
the engineers that live in the city
should be advanced enough
to have come up with something similar,
if not exactly the same
as the first plane to ever be made.
It would allow the city to check
for the incoming threat of titans
and allow the guards of the city
to either lure the Titans
away from the city or attack them
head on outside of the city walls.
That's when they get word
that the city's most skilled warriors,
the Scout Regiment, is back
from their titan hunt.
Eren drags Mikasa to see his beloved
heroes come back, but they quickly realize
that being a hero is costly,
expecting something out of a fairy tale .
He instead sees the men and women
of the Scout Regiment broken, bruised
and heavily traumatized
by their journey outside of the walls.
Back at home, Eren
speaks about how he wants to grow up
to slay titans, but his mom thinks otherwise.
She gets mad at him
for even suggesting the idea.
Eren's dad then gets up to leave for work,
but not before he reveals a key
to a secret basement and tells
Eren that when he gets back, he'll show him
what's down there.
But Eren has no idea the insanity
that awaits him down in that basement.
Later on, Eren sits with my cousin,
his best friend Armin, dreaming of a life
beyond these walls and what adventures
await him beyond this town.
And that's when their lives changed forever.
Suddenly, the whole town hears it.
A flash and rumble hits over the city walls.
Everybody goes to check it out
and realizes something.
It's terribly wrong.
They have no idea that they're about
to witness the most horrifying thing
that they've ever seen before a site
that nobody has seen in over 100 years,
a ginormous hand reaches over the walls.
It's a titan, and it blasts through the city
walls, reigniting storms
and hellfire upon everybody.
In Shiganshina City,
this 60 foot titan is an unstoppable force.
It tears through the walled gates, unleashing
an army of smaller titans right behind it.
Citizens begin dying left and right.
Men, women
and children are wiped out in seconds.
No one is safe from these bloodthirsty
titans as chaos reigns in the city.
Eren looks on in horror as he sees his house
destroyed at the feet of the Titans.
He rushes to check on his mother
and finds her trapped in the rubble.
But at that moment, a titan spots them
and begins to make its way towards them.
Eren is about to be crushed
along with his mother
until suddenly a familiar face shows up.
This blind guy who is ordered by the mother
to save her children and leave her behind.
Looking at his mother
sweet face one last time around,
and because they are dragged from their homes
as this blond guy carries
them away, helpless Eren can do nothing but
look in horror as his mother is picked up
and is devoured by the Titan.
OK, if I was Eren right now,
I would be shitting my pants.
After hearing about tie-ins for 100 years,
learning about them in school
and fearing their arrival
that day has finally come.
Now the first thing to do
would be to start running for cover.
We don't know much about the Titans,
but what we do know is that if we're targeted
by any of them, it's game over.
Also, the massive amounts of flying debris
caused by the Titans
is going to be something
we need to be extremely careful for.
We need to treat this
like a real life survival situation
if we're going to make it out of here alive.
Luckily for us, this city is densely packed,
leaving a lot of blind spots
where nobody can see us.
And while it might seem like a brutal
decision, we need to leave our mom behind
right where she is
because our house is on an elevated area,
meaning that it'll be easier
for the titans to see us there.
Either way, her legs are completely crushed,
and there's no way the two kids can carry
a fully grown adult around,
and we can clearly see
she's going to need medical attention,
which isn't going to be possible
with the current situation.
Now, even though it might seem
like a good idea
to find out where the rest of the citizens
went.
There's only one emergency
entrance out of Chicago up,
which means everyone will be running
towards the same direction,
which would increase our chances
of being spotted by the Titans.
I would say that's a bad plan.
It would be a good idea to carefully
make our way into a house near
the walls of Shiganshina,
and stay there for the time being.
Everybody's already
rushed out of their houses, meaning
there should be enough food and resources
for us to sustain ourselves for
at least a few days until we can wait it out.
As far as we know,
the Titans are simple minded creatures,
meaning they'll likely walk out of the city
if they don't manage to find any humans
for an extended period of time.
And also, they're far too big to easily
take a sneak
peek into any of the houses or, dare
I say , even the basement of the houses.
So we'll be safe there for the time being.
Countless citizens flee to the escape boats
that lay nearby as Eren and Mikasa join them,
sailing away
further deep into human territory.
But back at the gate, it's
a bloodbath blind guy here stands
with the other soldiers
who do their best to contain the damage.
They fire the cannons.
Everywhere at the Titans slowly
overpower the humans limited technology,
making a mockery of it,
causing some of the guards to panic
and flee their post and sprint
to the next gate to shut it for good.
Because these soldiers know what
we're thinking that if they don't get inside
the next wall, if they don't close this gate,
they will all die.
But that's when they see it.
The feet of another massive muscle bound
titan who begins charging directly
at the gate with full force,
no manmade weapon can stop the titan,
and so the guards run for their lives
as it blasts through the gate.
Nothing can stop this.
OK, if we've been forced into tiny,
walled off cities due to gigantic creatures
roaming right outside of our doorstep,
we should be
well prepared to take them head on
with the tools at our disposal.
Now, everyone in this city
knows that this day was going to come
sooner or later,
even though the walls are pretty high.
It's only a Band-Aid option
to the outside threat because if even one
titan spots evidence of human life
around the walls, it's all over.
However, not a single person in
the city was prepared for this moment,
which is about to get hundreds,
if not thousands, of people killed.
Now, this would require some prior thinking,
but hear me out.
The city's
designers should have built the city in a way
that wasn't so obvious from the outside,
even though we don't know
exactly how the creatures think.
If I was a titan roaming the wilderness,
then I might have done a double
take seeing a massive concrete
wall bigger than myself.
We clearly know that there are basements
built in the city because Eren's house
already has one.
In a way, the city government
should have prepared for this by making it
so every single house in the city
has some sort of underground basement
or bunker. However, it's
not a foolproof idea, especially
if your house is trampled on by a titan.
You might have some issues
getting out of the basement
with all of the debris blocking the way out,
but either way, being stuck.
Underground is better than being dead,
while this might not be the easiest situation
to deal with.
The first thing
the city guards should have done
would have been to keep the Titans
from getting past the city walls.
Considering that all of humanity as we know
it is contained within this little city,
they should have probably tried
to avoid having any of it destroyed
since it likely took decades of logistical
work to get it up and running
and the resources of the land around them
can't sustain them forever.
As the hours pass.
News of the fall of Shiganshina
on the south side of Wall
Maria reaches all the other territories.
After 100 years,
the Titans have finally begun to attack
mankind once again, and within that year,
all of humanity is forced to withdraw.
Behind the second wall, wall rose.
Thousands lay dead, and Eren is devastated
from the traumatic events.
They just happen, infused with rage.
He then vows to destroy the monsters
who took his mother from him.
The Titans themselves.
So with his budding relationship with Armin
and the watchful Mikasa,
they joined the Cadet Corpse Training School
in order to one day
rid the world of this titan threat over
the next three years.
Eren Armin and Mikasa train
like their lives depend on it,
and as the months pass, the three are tested
to their limits, learning the true nature
of what it takes to become humanity's
greatest weapon against the Titans.
As Aron learns that he's pretty bad
at everything but is helped to suck
a little bit less by his close
friend badass Annie Lionheart,
who knows a little bit more about combat
than all the other recruits
who try their best
to get through their hellish training.
Eren and his crew
find out that not many people have
firsthand experience
of seeing what the Titans are capable of.
Hell, some of them have just joined up
to look cool.
Most of them have no idea of what horrors
await them in the coming
days, months and years,
except for an unlucky few.
The group finds out, though most of the kids
here are really here just for show
to live up to society's expectations
with little idea of what is really going on.
Some signed up to simply join the easiest
and safest branch of them all
the military police
where they are tasked with doing little other
than guarding the king himself.
This is what humanity is counting
on these kiddos.
Humanity right now is doing a terrible job
of preparing these kids for what's to come.
Doing basic fitness
tests is a good way to tell
if they're physically tough enough
to handle a heightened threat,
but preparing them
mentally is a whole other challenge.
Only a few years earlier, the Titans came
through and destroyed half of the city,
and it's going to happen again very soon
while making sure the recruits are safe.
This is going to lead them to a false
sense of security that won't last forever.
It's important to note that the army
makes sure that the kids know what's coming,
and the best way to do that is to show them
the threat that they're dealing with head on.
If I were working for the army in this city,
I would propose that every student
form a group at the end of their training
for one final test.
Witness a titan in the flesh.
This may be extreme,
I know, but is this kind of rigorous training
that would benefit the rest of the army
the most and show these kids
what these monsters truly are?
This would instill fear into the recruits
and make sure that they're never
lazing around on the job.
Unlike these guys getting drunk and playing
games, in addition, it might be helpful
to teach every citizen in the city how to act
when an emergency situation arises.
A mandatory military conscription
would be a good way to harden the citizens
up to the harsh realities of the world there.
In many countries in the world,
like South Korea and Singapore promote
this very same idea to keep their citizens
ready in time of war.
This also might include familiar
the rising every single person
with the omnidirectional gear, since that's
the only known method of slaying a titan.
Their strength in numbers and the city needs
all the strength it can get.
The cadets finally graduate
and are given the options of joining three
different military branches
the garrison regiment
tasked with reinforcing the walls
and protecting the city.
The Military Police Regiment, which serves
to protect the king and maintain order.
And finally, the most dangerous group
of all the Scout Regiment,
which are tasked with surveying the dangerous
titan territories outside of the city
and one where lives are routinely lost.
Knowing the fate of the world
rests mainly upon one group,
Eren Mikasa and Armin decide
to join the Scout Regiment.
The group begins their daily life
as humanity's top defenders,
and for a while,
everything seems like it's going to be OK.
But nothing lasts forever, and on one
fateful day, the horrors return yet again.
Suddenly, a lightning strike
erupts in front of the trust gate,
bringing with it
another titan right in front of Eren himself.
A massive explosion erupts
in front of the Scout Regiment, sending
tons of young soldiers
to their death in seconds.
Eren holds on with his grappling hook
for his sweet life as he and
everyone else sees now the gaping hole right
within the giant wall itself.
The Titan invasion is happening again.
The massive titan bats the wall
mounted cannons away in one swift motion,
forcing everyone
to head for the gate entrance.
But something is up, and Eren notices
that this titan went for their defenses
immediately and knew which part of the wall
to hit these monsters are intelligent.
Herring goes on the offensive
and rides up the massive monolith of a titan
and tries to kill it at its weak spot,
but suddenly the Titan disappears
and now the city must seal off the entrance
before more smaller titans get in.
The city prepares for another attack
as everyone runs inward through the next gate
and the city forces put up defenses
and to lie and wait.
Because if the Titans get through this route,
it'll be just like what happened before.
They must hold off the Titans
and they need to seal off that eight
meter hole
if they don't all want to die right here.
And now humanity begins to arm itself
and readies for the incoming fight
as chaos reigns throughout the streets
right at the very heart of humanity
lives the king and this military, general
and badass bald guy.
They then received word
that the trust wall has been broken into
so bald guy like the stud that he is
prepared to go help his men.
But the king forbids him to leave,
arguing instead to stay here
to protect the Royal Castle, with the king
not giving one shit.
How many people die for him?
But Bald Guy is a bald stud and ignores
the king himself and goes to ready himself
for the bloodiest battle
his generation will ever face back
within the Trost district at the inner
second wall.
Wall Rose, Eren and his regiment
are given the orders by the Garrison Regiment
for battle plans to help save the city
because all the advanced teams at this moment
have been wiped out, which means Eren
and his group must hold their ground
against the fiercest beasts
this world has ever known the Titans
because if they don't do it,
then no one will.
OK, here we go again.
Now all that training that the recruits
didn't do is about to come back full circle.
However, it's too late
now to go back into the past and train
everyone properly, so we have to make use
of what we have right now.
The first thing we need to accept
is that people are probably going to die,
but as long as it isn't us, it's
OK with the group that we have right now.
It's in our best interest to take the Titans
on one by one, because splitting the teams
up is only going to make it harder
for us to take out the Titans.
And in doing so,
it's going to increase the amount of time
that the Titans have to wreck the city
and eat innocent civilians.
The best way to deal with them
is to isolate them first
and make sure the Titans don't surround us.
They're absolutely gigantic.
So as long as we keep our heads about us,
it shouldn't be too hard to avoid
any surprise attacks, and due
to the titans of limited cognitive abilities.
We should be able to get an edge on them
by using multiple people to distract them
while someone else aims
for the back of the neck.
Because while these times look like
slow moving creatures,
they seem to have the ability
to defy the laws of physics
moving much faster than any creature
that size should be able to.
This means not only
are they extremely dangerous,
but they're extremely unpredictable as well.
For us, we need to reduce that
unpredictability as much as possible.
Eren and Armin wait for the Titans
to reach their location as they talk about
defeating the Titans right here
and now and shooting up
to the very top of their ranks
within the regiment.
But Eren has no idea
just how difficult that is going to be.
The rest of Eren and Armin's squad, a group
34, shows up
just as they see the incoming titans
let the battle begin.
The gang then
charges forward, hurtling through the sky
and heading straight towards the titan.
But suddenly another time flies up right in
front of them and catches one of Eren's
teammates and his mouth, and it swallows him
right in front of all of Eren's friends.
The horrified gang is frozen in shock
as they watch their friend,
classmate and squad member die
right in front of them.
This enrages Eren,
who charges forward at that very same time
hurtling through the sky until SNAP!!!
A Titan bites his leg off,
causing him to crash on a nearby roof.
Armin does nothing
but watch his impure terror as all of
his squad mates are picked off,
one by one by the Titans.
It's a bloodbath, but he's too paralyzed
with fear to move a muscle and just then
another nearby Titan picks up
a petrified Armin is ready to devour him.
But Eren quickly gets up the last bit of his
strength and saves them, pulling him out
and away from the mouth of the Titans,
holding the Titans mouth open
until the Titan clamps his mouth shut.
This went way worse than we could have
possibly imagined, and this group
messed up big time
now to put the blame on one person.
But Eren royally screwed up this time around.
He got too emotional,
and that was his biggest mistake.
This guy had it out for the Titans
since day one.
And why wouldn't he?
They killed his mom right in front of him
and destroyed his childhood home.
It makes me wonder, though, similar
to joining the military,
I wonder if the cadet corpse
has any sort of psychiatric requirement
for entry because his disdain
for these monsters, while handy, is
what caused his downfall not addressing
emotional wounds from a traumatic past.
In most cases,
will almost always get worse over time.
And frankly, I'm surprised that Eren hasn't
resorted to coping with alcoholism
or food at this point.
Seeing his fellow teammates get eaten
was the last straw for him,
and this is what ultimately caused him
to lash out
and rage and ignore the group dynamic
and make a plan that could have prevented him
and all of his teammates
from getting in to begin with.
And I cannot emphasize
how much he screwed up,
but this little incident is going to be
the best and worst mistake he's ever made.
Amen.
The only survivor of Squad
34 snaps out of his day
state and runs off, unsure of himself
and the rest of the world's fate.
Because it's not looking good as people
and members of the regiment to try and escape
with fear and uncertainty leading the way
just as they see this one Titan,
come straight for them,
but to luckily for them,
more regiment members along with me
because I come and cut the titan down,
forcing its corpse to crash
right in front of the terrified citizens.
The public
finally gets a leg up on the evacuation
and all the regiments are forced to retreat.
But Mikasa Ops to help out
more of the trapped soldiers
in the nearby buildings crawling with titans.
But on the way there they encounter soldiers
who have run out of jumping gas
for their gear.
Thanks to the supply soldiers
within the headquarters
being too scared to do their job.
This means that the rest of the soldiers
outside can't scale the wall to retreat,
which means they're sitting ducks,
and it's only a matter of time
until more titans find them.
But this one cadet ain't taking no shit
at what life throws at him,
and with few other options, demands
that they attack the headquarters
so they can resupply themselves
with more gas at once.
And Mikasa joins in and convinces
the squad that they can do it
and also spots a sullen Armin,
who sits nearby, defeated and then Mikasa
a learns that Eren
and the entirety of the 34th Squadron
has been wiped out,
causing her to reel back in shock.
Her only family left is dead.
Mikasa quickly recovers and states that
she will retake the headquarters with them
or without them, and everyone is shocked
with how calloused and cold Mikasa is.
Mikasa and the group sets off
with what little gas they have left
and goes flying across the sky.
And Armin notices
that Mikasa is going too fast and burning
through her gas too much,
and he realizes something.
She misses Eren and just letting her emotions
guide her decisions.
But suddenly Mikasa drops out of the sky,
heading the rooftop with a bone
crunching thud.
She contemplates giving up right
then and there, and with the titans on her
tail, is about to get eaten
until another titan comes in swinging.
Beating this other titans senseless
and not trying to attack her arm
just then arrives in the nick of time
and picks up Mikasa
but me because I can't believe
what she's seeing a titan fighting
another titan using humanlike movements
to defeat this other monster.
Holy shit, this is insane.
We're used to seeing these monsters fighting,
but we have to be scrupulous enough
to always pay attention to the little things
I want to point something out.
Most titans fight like that of some animal
with lower intelligence
fighting like wild animals,
swinging their arms
and using their teeth
to bite as a form of offense.
But this titan fights
like someone with a higher IQ.
He isn't swinging his arms,
is what I'm saying.
So Mika's and a group need to calm down
and get to the bottom of this because
whatever this new kind of kindness,
all we know right now is that it's
absolutely terrifying,
Mika Son Arman said in shock,
but have little time to react
as the other soldiers say they need to get
to the supply headquarters now.
But Mikasa is out of gas.
Arman then gives Mikasa
his equipment and has an idea.
If they take out the nearby titans, they can
then lead this seemingly humanlike titan
that they've just discovered
to the supply headquarters.
The gang agrees and heads out,
killing the other nearby titans
and aiding this one
and leading it to the supply HQ.
As more and more regiment members are killed,
they finally reached the headquarters
as the other members here for Mikasa
that they have an ally on their side.
This raging titan, the group
then prepares themselves with weaponry
and heads to the Titan filled basement, where
all their supplies lie waiting for them.
Armin quickly devices a plan and the soldiers
prepared to blind all the titans
down there, along with a few extra soldiers
to stay up hidden in the scaffolding
to surprise attack that the team
then huddles up in the lift and descends down
into hell itself, with the platform
slowly lowering down until the group
finally lays eyes on the Titans,
luring them in step by step,
waiting for the perfect moment
until they fire blinding the titans
and allowing the troops from the scaffolding
to descend from above and cut them down.
The gang then resupplies their gas tanks
and prepares themselves
for the ensuing fight of a lifetime.
The squadron
finally begins to ascend the wall
and get the hell out of there, but Mikasa
remains behind as she and Armin cede
their mysterious titan ally
getting cannibalized by the other titans.
She suggests that they save this titan,
and some other members know
better than to pass on this incredible chance
of a lifetime to have a titan ally, and
they offer to help them mucosa and arm it.
But suddenly they see their titan break free
and kill every single other
titan in the area,
kicking ass and taking names
until it collapses,
surrounded by a field of smoke.
But at that moment,
they see the most insane thing ever.
A human body breaks
free from the back of this titan's neck.
It's Eren!
Mikasa's eyes bulge white
as she runs to go investigate
seeing a fully formed area
with all of his limbs intact.
Elsewhere, the elite scouting team returns
back to a swarm of titans,
and they swiftly take them out.
But this one guy then mentions that
a swarm of titans have begun moving northward
towards the main city, forcing the scouts
to move back within the trost district.
Armin and Mikasa try and help
a tired Eren back up to his feet,
but they're not out of this shit just yet
because they've just made the biggest mistake
of their lives, and it could cost them
everything suddenly surrounding the group,
an entire regiment of soldiers
aim and draws their weapons.
Ready to kill Eren right here
and now thinking he's a titan in disguise,
which means Mikasa and Armin by helping
Eren have committed an act of treason.
Mikasa draws her sword and is ready to kill
anyone who tries to kill Eren.
Eren pleads to everyone that he's
one of the good guys, but no one believes
and this bearded captain is done listening,
so he orders to destroy them right here
and now with a blast from a cannon
at that moment.
Mikasa grabs Eren and Armin, and they try
to make a run for it, but it's too late.
Suddenly, the pull of me
because they're grabbing Eren
makes his key flip out in front of his face,
unlocking a memory of his dad, telling him
that if Wall Maria ever goes down,
he needs to go find
what's hidden in the basement of his house.
Eren is shocked to realize
that his dad must have drugged him,
and that the key is the answer
to all of this.
OK, we have no idea just
what the hell happened, but if I were Eren,
I would try to be as non-confrontational
as possible at this very moment.
This is a delicate situation,
and acting with any kind of aggression
or desperation is likely to get us killed.
I would tell me because I'm here
to stand down and let me represent myself
because there's no way in hell
that acting like I did nothing wrong
is going to work
from the perspective of the guards.
It's only going to make us look like
we're a group of undercover
titans working together
to get this city destroyed.
People know that Mikasa and Eren
have been friends since they were kids,
so of course
she would want to come to Eren's rescue,
no matter what the situation, to avoid
looking like a suspicious piece of shit.
I would calmly tell the dozens of soldiers
pointing their guns that we have no idea
just what the hell happened.
Honesty is key at any sign of foul play is
going to result in all of our instant demise.
Looking at it
logically, Eren was swallowed by a titan,
meaning that
he's definitely not on their side.
That time was out to kill him,
just like any other military force here.
However, if he can somehow turn into a titan,
this is monumental.
They should be using Eren for their own good
because he was clearly attacking other
titans, which means that at a bare minimum,
he still retained a bit of his consciousness.
While in Titan form, Eren then remembers
everything that his dad tried
to make him forget, biting his finger
and transforming yet again into a titan.
This terrifies everyone, as Beard Guy
looks at Eren
in sheer horror, thinking,
Who the hell is this guy?
Eren wakes up merged with muscle tissue,
breaking free from his Titan creation.
Meanwhile, Armin looks at him in shock.
This isn't the errand that he wants new.
This is something else.
Eren then jumps down and meets up with
the two remembering his dad and the basement.
He's the reason for all of this.
Mikasa then focuses on Eren
as they figure out a plan to get out of here,
but Eren's nose is suddenly bleeding
and his face looks pale.
Looks like being a titan
is taking its toll on him.
Eren then tells the truth that they shouldn't
try and help him,
but Marcus isn't having any of it,
and neither is Armin, who steps up and tries
to convince the garrison regiment
just outside of the fog that he is no threat.
But Beard Guy doesn't believe him
and is about to tell the cannons
to fire again until Commander Bald Guy stops
witnessing the finest soldier salute
that Arman has ever given.
Commander Bald Guy cuts the kids a break
because he believes them OK.
If I'm going up against all the military
branches, it's unlikely
unless by some acts of God that we'd be able
to convince them that we're not a threat.
It may seem counterintuitive,
but our safest option was running away
if it wasn't for Commander Bald Guy.
There's already so much we don't know
about the Titans, like where they come from.
Hell, we barely know how to kill them.
If Eren didn't have Commander Bald Guy,
then I would have seriously contemplated
bolting the hell out of there,
because not even our titan turning friend
can explain to us
how he can turn into a titan .
Yet Commander Bald Guy
then takes them up on the wall
where he hears them out, and even Armin shows
he's cut out for soldier's life
by offering the best plan
that anyone has ever heard.
He tells the commander
that Eren and Titan form can lift up
the big boulder stuck within the town
and fill the gaping hole
at the wrecked entrance, which can in turn
stop all titans from reentering.
Finally, reclaiming the trust district,
the commander agrees
to go along with this desperate plan,
and so does Eren.
However, whether he actually has the strength
to lift that rock or not
is another question.
The commander sets the plan in motion,
luring away a majority of the titans
to one corner of the wall, while Eren tries
to move the giant boulder to the entrance
without having to take on
any other titans and takes alongside him
an elite squad of soldiers to accompany him.
This is a plan with a terrifyingly high rate
of failure, and hundreds of people will die.
Everything and everyone relies on this plan.
They all rely on Erik.
They cannot afford to mess this up.
The commander convinces the terrified masses
to help on this one last mission.
To stop the Titans to save humanity
and humanity
responds to his call and rallies
up to try and fight.
one more time.
And so the plan begins with Eren
and his little squad running towards
the site of the giant Boulder,
and Eren finally transforms
into his horrifying Titan state.
But something is not right
because Eren turns around and suddenly tries
to kill Mikasa, his best friend.
Eren, now in full rage mode,
continuously tries to kill Mikasa,
and she tries to convince this titan
that she's a part of his family.
But this glasses guy sees the plan backfire
and fires the red flare up into the sky.
Confirming to everybody
that the plan has failed Mikasa, however,
through her cunning,
this makes Eren knock himself out whilst
the other group of soldiers now
think of a new plan.
But they don't have time to think because
two tines have just been spotted nearby.
The group contemplates to leave Eren here,
but Mikasa thinks that there's still hope
back on the other side of the wall.
The soldiers
see the red flare high up in the sky
and think their titan plan has failed,
forcing Armin to think fast and run off.
But Commander Bald Guy
here tells the group to hold
because just like Mikasa,
he still has faith in Eren.
Back at the side of the boulder,
Mikasa convinces the team to believe in Eren,
forcing them to keep the Titans busy
until they can recover it.
But even more titans begin to show up
near Eren, forcing the team
to split up and kick some ass.
But in the midst of all of this.
Armin gets near Eren and
tells him the situation not getting anywhere.
Armin takes out his sword and slices
right into Eren's
body, is stabbing his arm
and waking him the hell up.
And this time for the better.
Eren, in his tight end form,
picks up the boulder
and begins walking towards the trust entrance
just as the Garrison Regiment
and the Scout Regiment tag team
all of these titans circling nearby.
It's a bloodbath, but it gets the job done,
allowing an exhausted
Eren to finally plug the hole and pass out.
Armin then comes to get Eren out of his
tightened body right as the remaining titans
inside the wall try and attack them.
But just then, the best of the best comes
in swinging to save the day.
It's the elite scout regiment saving the day
and helping the humans take out.
The remaining titans gathered in bunches
near the wall, saving trust for now.
Later, Eren wakes up bound and caged
with the Scout Regiment,
taking responsibility for him and holding
the one thing that could save them all.
The key to his father's basement?
OK, hold up.
These guys just took the most valuable thing
that we have right now.
If I was Eren,
I would try to convince this guy
and the rest of the Scout Regiment
to look more into my father, because it's not
that far
fetched to think that my dad, a scientist,
might have something
to do with my titan abilities.
It makes sense, logically,
that I was his first human guinea pig.
A simple result of his experiments
because at this point, they won't
get any more information out of me,
since I don't know anything else.
They should really save us both some time
and look more into the man
likely behind all of this.
My scientist father himself.
But now's not the time for saving the world
because the public then decides
that Eren will first
have to fight his way in court
to see if he really belongs
with the humans or not.
But the Scout Regiment, unlike the rest,
wants to use Eren to retake the wall outside
of the District of Trost, Maria But
the public doesn't trust Eren even one bit.
So the Scout Regiment gets creative
and beats the shit out of him,
showing that only the Scout Regiment
can handle a beast of this nature.
And so the court agrees to hand him over
to the best of the best.
A scout regiment
who plan to take back Wall Maria by heading
back to Eren's hometown,
Shiganshina later on the way.
There, the gang stops over at an Old Scout
Regiment post
where Eren comes face to face
with some of the best scouts in the world.
And these scouts are not like the rest
because, unlike most of society,
the scouts think Eren is too valuable to kill
and they need to prove it.
Later at dinner, Eren meets a mad scientist,
or she might as well be this glasses girl
who asks Eren for help with her experiments
that she's running on two captured titans
experiments in communication shooting
titans from sunlight, what makes them less
active overall, and finding out that
they don't need food or water to survive?
Nor do they breathe, telling
Eren that based on what she found?
The only thing that titans rely on
is sunlight.
Hey, guys.
Griffin
here just want to pop in really quickly,
we want to be able to show you each story
in all of its full, gory details,
but we don't want to get flagged.
We already had "another" video
get flagged.
So in order to fix that, we're setting up
our very own Patreon account.
It's going to be set up very soon,
so keep an eye out for updates.
Glasses girl then goes over all of her
terrifying theories as to who are what
the Titans are and talks Eren's ear
off the whole night until morning comes
and they find out that someone has killed
their test subjects.
The doctor
then loses her shit as they try to figure out
which person or group of persons did this.
It seems like that
there is a traitor in the Scout Regiment.
The Scout Regiment
then conducts an investigation into
who exactly killed
these valuable Titan test subjects.
As captain of the Scout Squadron, Badass
Captain Levi grabs Eren and others
to join him on a scout mission
just as another higher up, then announces
to all the young rookies that the scouts
now have open spots to join in their ranks.
But while most of the peeps in the 104th
regiment decide to join the scouts,
Annie decides to join the military police
in spite of all of her other comrades.
The higher ups also convinced the rookies
that they now have a secret weapon to beat
the Titans located
in the home of Eren Yeager's basement.
But in order to get there,
they need to take back Wall Maria
and take out all of the horrifying
titans that wait for them there.
And they start scares the hell
out of the young recruits, and most end up
walking away, leaving behind only a brave few
willing to take on the worthy cause.
Little do all these recruits know
that many of them will die soon enough
over the course of time.
The recruits begin training for what will be
the most dangerous day of their lives,
learning various combat and formation drills
until the fateful day arrives.
And the Scout Regiment, including Eren, Armin
and Mikasa roll out to take back
Shiganshina District and find the hidden
secret hidden within Eren's basement.
They crossed the plain lush terrain and
they carry out their formation, distracting
Titan's left and right and allowing
for the various platoons to advance deeper
into enemy territory until they see one
titan headed straight for arm.
But this titan is no ordinary titan.
It's something far deadlier
and one with insane intelligence
defeating this scout here with ease, with
his eyes locked onto Armin in the distance.
It looks to be a titan,
just like Eren's a human titan.
The female titan stomps at Armin
on the other side.
The Titans have broken the scout formation.
Many scouts have been eaten or killed.
The female titan slowly goes to grab Armin,
but instead she only takes off his hood
to check him out before running away.
Could this be the human trader,
the one who sabotaged
the scouts experiments from earlier?
Okay, this changes everything.
If having Eren turn into a titan
wasn't crazy enough,
we now know that there is another human
like titan roaming around.
This opens the door
to a number of possibilities.
first,
there might be a number of different people
that can turn into titans, which is both
the scariest and most interesting news
that the human race has learned in the past
100 years.
If that tells us anything, Eren's
transformation wasn't a fluke.
He is part of a very special group of humans
that has the potential
to change the landscape of the world.
Now, if I were the Scout Regiment
leader, I'd be less interested
in hunting these titans down
and more interested in finding out
how the hell Eren managed
to turn into a titan.
And I would wonder if anyone else
not only in the group
but in the city would be able
to pull off the same thing.
Just then, another scout comes by
with a horse for Armin and the duo meet
another member
while they chase down this female titan.
Armin tells them that this monster is part
human and part titan, and that
he thinks her goal isn't to eat people,
but to find someone else.
And she hasn't eaten anybody
that they've seen her kill.
And so she must be the one who let the Titans
in when the first wall fell.
The team then figures out a new attack plan
to distract her from heading towards the rear
formation to prevent her from finding Eren
or wiping out the rest of the squad or both.
They need to buy time
so everybody can retreat.
The team spreads out to cover the female
titan from both sides, but this monster
catches on quick and swats Armin away
like a fly, knocking him off his horse.
But he thinks fast and yells out
that Eren's been killed, stopping
the female titan from killing this guy.
But just then, this other scout grapples
onto her and flings himself up into the sky
until he gets caught.
And he breaks out like a Japanese
Edward Scissorhands and grabs
Armin and heads off with this other dude.
While the horrifying female
titan goes in the other direction, probably
straight for air back near Eren's location,
he sees a black smoke signal near him,
indicating that there's an abnormal
titan nearby and it's not looking
good as the female titan continues
to decimate small squadrons.
Soldiers left and right,
brutally killing them all.
Destroying the formation,
the female titan forces the scouts
to make a new plan and take a position
within this nearby forest to intercept
any titans that pass by here, including
confronting the human titan herself.
They cannot afford to retreat.
Just an errant squad enters the forest,
but shit's already hit the fan.
The human titan is right behind them,
horrifyingly eyeing Eren like a predator
to its prey, quickly killing all rear
reinforcements like they are.
Nothing forcing
Captain Levi and his squad to keep Eren safe
and continue pressing on at top speed.
Despite the horrors of seeing their squad
mates die uselessly left and right.
Suddenly, a blast of 1000 grappling
hook stop this Titan dead in her tracks,
trapping her while Eren and his squad
finally managed to get away.
The scouts are going to get a look at
whoever's inside of her one way or another.
But this titan is a beast
and best every attempt the scouts make to try
and cut out the person hiding inside of her,
and it's about to get a whole lot worse.
Just then, the female titan lets out
a raging roar, calling all the titans
in the area being distracted by the scouts
to come save her.
The female titan forces the regiment
to think fast and kill every single creature.
They're cutting off limbs, heads
and napes of necks, but it's no use.
The Titans quickly
overwhelm the squad and begin to cannibalize
the female titan, forcing the regiment
to withdraw and return to base.
But something is not right
as steam begins to form around the gathering
titans, meaning the person inside
the Titan has a chance to escape .
But unlike Eren, the person inside the female
titan is able bodied and more advanced,
and she attacks the retreating forces,
killing off scout members near Eren before
turning back into another female titan.
The squad then tells Eren to go on
without them
while they take on the female titan.
This group of scouts is a cut above the rest
and decimate this titan until they don't,
because this female titan has some tricks up
her sleeve and eventually kills each
and every one of the scouts
finest, forcing a scared and enraged
Eren to swing back
and take up the mantle of Titan Killer again,
transforming into the only thing
strong enough to kill a titan.
Another Titan Eren
does everything that he can, but he fails,
sadly outmatched, and she chops his titan
head off and swallows air.
In all, Mikasa reaches them just in
time to see her family
get taken away from her again,
forcing her to dance with death itself.
Cutting this titan down to its knees
while Captain Levi
swings in and helps Mikasa
a safe eren from the Titans mouth
just in the nick of time before running away
and heading back to the main city.
The operation has failed, with the Scout
Regiment losing more than just soldiers,
but of losing friends as well, forcing
the support of the Scout Regiment over
Eren to collapse, causing him to be handed
back over to the capital's custody.
But thanks to Armin
and this guy's determined scout regiment,
they realize who the female titan really is
turning out to be the very same person
who killed those titans used for experiments
and the same one who trained with Eren
and the 104th Cadet Corps.
The gang knows who the female titan is
and sets out with a plan to trap her inside
a nearby tunnel come morning.
The next day finally arrives,
and they set the plan in motion, with Armin
asking his dear old friend
within the military police Annie Leonhard,
if she can help them with Eren's escape.
And she eagerly agrees with this group
being led down this eerily empty street
until they reach some stairs
leading down to some underground tunnels.
But something is not right, as Annie feels
something is off, and she realizes
that they know that she's the female titan
Annie, then ready to bite her finger.
I tell a bunch of other people stop her
and tire up, but they're no match for her
as she has a secret ring
that has a hidden blade in it and once more
turn into the horrifying female titan
she was onto them from the start.
OK, I love my attack on Titan crew
as much as the next guy,
but I need to point something out.
We probably should have known that Annie was
the female titan by looking at her features
because no one else in the 104th
regiment has the same features like she does.
And not even that there were even more
telltale signs
that she was no ordinary scout.
Hindsight is 2020,
but the way the female titan looked
and moved back in
the forest was near identical to Annie.
Not only that,
the female titan did no harm to Armin,
even though he was completely helpless.
Now this is what I would do
without telling anyone else in the group.
I would take this opportunity to strike
as soon as possible
at any moment that she turns her back.
We need to take her down and subdue her
and, dare I say, even kill her.
Because if we're fast enough, we could have
avoided this city being destroyed once again.
And there's too many things that can go
wrong.
She's way too dangerous to take any chances.
The scouts should have either
tried to capture her killer
like I went The minute
they found out the news,
they should have done everything
that they could do
to make this job easier on themselves.
And one of the biggest parts would have been
to sedate her in some way, rather
than just relying on brute force
of a bunch of people trying to capture her.
They should have been way more cautious.
I should have used everything
at their disposal to take her down.
Armin milk aside, Eren
then get trapped in the tunnel
with the female titan blocking both.
Exits, leaving them trapped with no way out.
And to top off the bad news, Eren can't
turn into a titan choking at the last minute.
This forces Mikasa and Armin to act as decoys
and split up to confuse the female titan.
But to add even more bad news,
Eren gets stepped on
by the female titan, crushing him
good and trapping him beneath some rubble.
But this isn't over yet and Armin sure
as shit knows it, sneaking over to trapped
Eren as more and more scouts and fighters
scramble to the female titan's location.
But she is unstoppable and knows
all of their moves before they make it.
If Armin doesn't get Eren to act fast,
they're all dead, so armed with nothing
but his words breaks through to Eren,
allowing Eren to regain his tiny abilities
and turning him
back into the unstoppable beast
that everyone fears a titan ready
to kill Annie.
Eren, now a fully formed titan killing
machine, attacks Annie, the female titan
with more veracity and madness
than ever thought possible, swinging his fist
with more raw power than rocky,
swinging at raw meat and smashes Annie down,
forcing her to take it up a notch and fight
dirty, beating the crap out of her
and smashing his head in dozens of times,
allowing her to run off.
But this time
something is different within Eren,
and he's lost too many good friends
to let their deaths be in vain, forcing
something within him to unveil
and unleash more fury than ever before.
Eren that engulfs his titan body with flames,
lighting up his eyes
with an electric blue glow and runs to chase
Annie down.
Annie, overwhelmed by Eren's ferocity,
proceeds to climb up the wall,
allowing her to escape
and return to attack again.
But Mikasa has other plans
and swings up with vengeance in her eyes
and cuts Annie's fingers clean off,
causing her to fall back down
hard and falling into
what might as well be hell itself.
Eren in Titan form attacks
Annie severing Annie from her
Titan body, scooping her out like human
ice cream.
Eren is either ready to kill her
or hand her over, but just then, in a last
ditch self-defense effort, Annie,
in case is herself in Diamond Rock,
just as Captain Levi comes
in swinging to save Eren from his titan body.
Annie is now encased in this diamond shell,
and they're unable
to pry the secrets
that they desperately need to know from her.
The city eventually hands off
Annie to be under the Scout Regiments Care
Deep Underground, and Eren gets off the hook,
letting him and Annie rest,
ensuring that all of their titan secrets
to remain undiscovered for now.
But what do you think?
Let us know down in the comments below
what you like and what you didn't like.
Don't forget to subscribe.
Check out our playlist
and also give us a thumbs up.
And don't forget to
check out our social media.